beh ragazzi e benvenuti simi a questo
nuovo video di youtube e slide perché
giampiero oggi è carico per seguirmi in
tutta la città di youtube quanto pare è
buona visione
oggi blog è il miglior contenuto oggi se
faccio un blog fa virus ierino così vado
a fare un blog su un camion che sta per
i mesi in un vecchio ma cosa sto vedendo
se creata una fila perché questo sta con
telephone pagata bellissimo da geniale
scusi se gente come passare prima per
niente di mani pure la fatica sito è
fatto fare un blog sulla macchina nella
metro che a cascata è bassa e poi me ne
vado a casa
no non c'è più forte tra finalmente
volevo fare una roba ma dai per una
volta le spalle non sinergizzare cui
trend a rho devo trovare un buon punto
per loggare ragazzi non so dove però non
ho la minima idea su un piccione fermo
ma basta si vecchi che ferma cosa ma col
dove come per quando i vecchi che
fermano bene in mezzo alla strada la
gente sta cosa non fa capisco registra
un video ma basta fare interviste kick
ass a blog blog che perfetto di
una guardo ogni volta che di mangiare
come se fosse importante la vita è che
palle vai mangia finito bene guarda
questo blog madonna e fastidio
inizia saluti il canale bene a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo blog che ho
appena mangiato e router o un sacco che
lasci scappare volta forma con la mazzeo
palesemente cioè non è quello il modo di
tale axn
stiamo qua
negativi i follower per il supporto di
asi scappare una frase di pd poi forse
un'informazione utile sto capendo la sto
facendo la mente è stato un gran video
bellis chissà che cazzo detto per due
ore guardando la camera senza un perché
però va bene salve marley ziggy fi2 voi
io devo dare questo video che già è
difficile registrare qua ci manca solo
mangiato perché se non possiamo stare
vito giampiero si è lentamente utile non
so come ringraziarti per l'aiuto che mi
stai dando edita video 2 3 e 4
utilizzato al massimo pubblica vito
l'espoir la quale il sole che mi copre
titolo del video
il blog più brogli spiaggia
va bene il blog più prolifica e mettiamo
sta roba vediamo quanto vale almeno 200
lai che vogliono perde 2 a 26 questi sei
risultati nella vita basta adesso sono
realizzato ma dovevi niente giorno di
san valentino il giorno di san valentino
senza lager giorno di san valentino
andiamo al limon a pallavolo sfida di
ballo giorni stamattina posso usare
tutte e tre vado a ballare con una
pallavolista per san valentino mela
rimuovono fanno saltare un miliardo di
youtube naturalmente utilizzano con
evidente le poche giornate sui social io
che sono single
ma [ __ ] a provare i morchia
ragazzi però non so bene come si fa
neanche una vita reale in realtà e
quindi è un bene più realistico che mi
piace
ap calo se riesco ad arrivare al
bla bla bla bla un reset terza
f k e sport markt jacquard rimorchiare
non vai e un esportatore vabbè ma dorme
che
lucy ciao sono lussi a farci giocare mi
chiamo famigie sulla nuova in città
capisco un piccolo consiglio dovrà
entrare a far parte dell'elite degli
stranieri ha detto guardaroba
grazie a un cuore vuol dire che un po ti
interessa
c'è più o meno ti darò un consiglio
spassionato l'immediata rete gianni
lizzare il tuo guarda ho capito minchia
quelle fissate porca [ __ ] col con
look
oddio
oddio caso venendo la zia la zia che
iniziato a giocare
porca vacca e fortissimo tra l'altro non
è giusto che oltre non funzionava la
rivincita battere tempi facevate nel mio
gatto a scacchi o battute migliori
genitorialità non mi fai paura mandala
yunfei fortissima ma va bene prova
rimorchiare qualcuno che non è
interessata per forza quello che vestono
grazie blejer ciao 69 gitane vero sì che
a vincere ma mi hai veduto 62.000 giochi
quindi
sono visto lo per me delle torneo non
stressare ma la gestisco posso proprio
pensa di me vieni ti ho portato del riso
roy
come grazie credo come credo a fan
curativa limonare adesso ha una foto
insieme aspetta possiamo farlo insieme
eq neviani catture vieni qua vi dico
chapeau d'insieme cambia cosa sto per
rimorchiare una gnocca strappa una mille
like ma è l'età cuore perché pubblicato
la foto con te c'è anche un video
youtube e specifiche perché parli al mio
culo sono visto prevalere per non
stressare ma c è meta cuore ma scusa va
bene credo che io possa interagire in
questi tre modi solo una volta al giorno
credo è sfida di etica si gratis grazie
biglietti grassi del play con la posso
ancora fare prova che mi manca una foto
mi spiace non è ancora pubblica tutte le
tre foto si mai paura che giampiero la
repubblica di notte solo per quello
posso provare a vedere se riesco a farne
un'altra però le devo pubblicare tutte
lo stesso giorno raga non si può fare
camion e devo accorgere subito quando
c'è sta gente devo andare a controllare
subito perché se non controllo subito
poi non posso più fare le foto perché
giampiero non fa le foto di notte ma
queste player porca vacca devo posso
finire di rimorchiarla blair il tutto
sto casino
veniamo videogiochi che domande mai e
poi mai avere madonna quanto e scontrosa
sta stronza però facciamo una bella foto
e per chi porta un altro regalo e
teoricamente dovrebbe essere fidanzati
col cuore come puoi lasciarti scappare
un ragazzo così belli e la gente mente
laiche come vi farete gli manca ha un
cuore pieno bellissimo e quindi no manca
un regalo perché se io aggiungo un
regalo teoricamente ma posso comprare un
gioco per lei signora c'è un gioco per
lei questo ho comprato da lei e moglie
un regalo ci pensi e lo prende fa troppo
ridere
mai venduto tue grazie credo verrà
venduto tubik a oggi sono voluti pochi
clienti ho passato tutto il giorno ha
commentato immagini sinistra ed ora mi
sono rotta sai il mio amico edgar
collezione oggetti particolari magari
qualcosa di divertente un nuovo gioco
per edgar i tickets ed è garantito è che
si parli non si vogliono sviluppatori di
spider pro puoi provarlo ma sono i live
streaming sai come fare una diretta
streaming ma certo di che cazzo parliamo
sembra che il giovane abbia la funzione
streaming quindi perchè non vai la
consolle ci provi poi ti spiegherò
constatare questa voce sul trono ok se
installare questa frase sul tutelare
fare la diretta streaming casa tua devia
da recenti innovazioni earth è gratuito
earning out se vuoi provare il gioco spy
dato alla metà del prezzo in cui verrà
venduto tra due giorni da venerdì ma
adesso dai lo voglio ecco premio
divertiti a lui è il capo di al tecnico
arming out voglio che giampiero possa
fare gli streaming
bellissimo bellissimo capisco poi
migliorare e botti youtube lo vogliono
quanti soldi avrà trazione perché per la
funzione streaming avviare bastard dax
ti chiedono raccoglie vicini questo
subito crisi si fa così
ai droni stanno qua
maxx power ii e la madonna
droni e carina kato che in italia non
era il fegato devo andare sul retro per
questa ecco qual è il retro dimmi che
non costa tanto ti prego funzione
streaming 2.000 duemila ragazzi costa
tantissimo
siete dei maledetti cioè costa tutto qua
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
cosa momento è un mi piace nel prossimo
episodio cerchero di rimorchiare serie
di schede anche adesso se serve si tira
ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
perché giampiero e scarico beh ragazzi
[Musica]